Olive Oatman: Life among the Mohave
Even those who aren't familiar with the name
"Olive Oatman" are undoubtedly familiar with
her photo.
The young, dark-haired girl with the solemn
expression and distinctive chin tattoo has
become synonymous with the hardships faced
by the pioneers who set out as a part of America's
Westward Expansion, a mass migration that
helped shape the middle of the 19th century.
Even as thousands of intrepid settlers made
their way across the Midwestern plains on
the Oregon Trail, groups of Mormon pilgrims
headed to another destination: Salt Lake City.
And still others headed deep into the southwestern
deserts for reasons that were entirely their
own — and that is where the Oatman family
was going when they were waylaid at the place
now memorialized with a single, plain sign
that reminds travellers what happened there:
the Oatman Massacre.
The teenage Olive survived the attack that
killed most of her family, and experienced
a life that few lived to tell of.
She's most famous for her time spent among
the Native American tribes of the American
southwest, but her story begins much earlier
than that: with visions, prophecy, and religious
fervor.
The road to Hell is paved with good intentions
Emigrants who packed up everything and left
the relative comfort of the East Coast for
the wild landscape of the West did so for
all kinds of reasons.
Some looked for new opportunities, some were
just out for adventure, and some, well, it
wasn't so much about where they were going
but what they wanted to leave behind.
For the Oatman family, their foray into the
Western frontier began with the revelations
of a prophet.
Roys Oatman and his wife, Mary Ann, had seven
children between 1834 and 1849.
It was also during those years that the Methodist
family converted to Mormonism, after being
inspired by the prophecies and texts revealed
by Joseph Smith.
For those not familiar with the foundations
of Mormonism, it's worth a quick aside to
understand just why the Oatman family would
leave the relative safety of Vermont and head
west.
Smith claimed to have found a set of golden
plates that he was able to translate with
the help of an angel.
He preached that it was their duty to seek
out the City of Zion, and along the way, they
met with a lot of resistance.
Believers were tarred and feathered, run out
of town, and persecuted for their beliefs.
And there were a lot of believers — including
Roys and his family.
In 1844, Smith announced he was going to run
for the presidency; however, not all those
who considered themselves Mormon agreed with
the move, or all of his teachings, for that
matter.
One of the most controversial was polygamy,
and it was enough to splinter his followers
into other groups.
After Smith destroyed a press run by one of
these rival factions, he called on the local
militia for help.
He was arrested, jailed, and on June 27, a
mob broke into the jail and killed him.
One of the rival factions that had been such
a thorn in Smith's side was headed by a boy
named James Colin Brewster.
Brewster had been only 10 years old when rumors
of his gift of prophecy began to circulate,
and at first, the mainstream Mormon elders
believed he was a genuine seer.
Buoyed by this, Brewster started bringing
the revelations fast and furious, ultimately
writing — with the help of his father — a
text he called the book of Esdras.
Included in the text was a description of
the promised land.
It was a land destined to be the gathering
place of saints, and it was called Cedonia,
the Land of Bashan.
Brewster claimed that the land was in a remote
corner of the country, somewhere in the southwest.
Smith and the mainstream church denounced
Brewster as a fraud, and Brewster gathered
his own following — appropriately, they
were called the Brewsterites, and more formally,
they were the Church of Christ.
The Oatman family were among Brewster's followers,
and at the time Smith was killed, the young
would-be prophet was just 17 years old.
But that, many decided, was old enough to
lead the faithful to the promised land — even
though he had been officially excommunicated
from the Mormon church before Smith died.
His prophecies began to get more specific,
and he claimed their final destination was
on the river "Amli", which he claimed was
another name for the Rio Grande.
So it came to pass that on August 5, 1850,
the Oatman family left Missouri in a group
of about 90 people.
There were 17 different families in their
little caravan, made up of 27 wagons, a few
hundred cattle, and — as it would turn out
— quite a bit of strife.
Just a few more names among the thousands
of dead
Today, traveling across the country can be
done in a day.
AIrlines are uncomfortable and inconvenient
and one of those modern luxuries no one really
likes, but it's almost an infinite improvement
over the conditions in which the Oatman family
— and thousands of other families — needed
to try to survive on their trek westward.
One in ten people who set out just on the
Oregon Trail didn't survive.
It was an active route for only 25 years,
but it still has the dubious distinction of
being America's longest graveyard with around
65,000 graves scattered along the way — that's
one burial every 50 yards from Missouri to
Oregon City.
There was no shortage of ways to die.
Disease was rampant, and in some cases, a
person who was perfectly healthy in the morning
would be dead by dusk.
There was cholera and scurvy, malaria, and
of course, there was always the possibility
of snakebites, falls, broken bones, infections,
and accidental gunshot wounds — something
that happened more often than you might expect.
Just imagine the hardships: surviving on nothing
more than the dried food you could carry and
what you could hunt.
Dust and dirt that infected every nook and
cranny.
And — if you were among the later settlers
that set off — you were following in the
footsteps of thousands of other people and
animals… and trekking through all the waste
they left in their wake.
It's truly not surprising that tempers might
be running wild, and that conflict within
groups who needed to stay together for safety
might be commonplace.
Things only got worse for the Brewsterites
as they left the plains and headed into the
mountains of New Mexico, traveling a route
known to the natives as Jornada Del Muerto,
or the Journey of Death.
It wasn't just difficult terrain, either — it
was one of the longest, hottest, and driest
years on record, and those that lived there
were getting desperate.
As the caravan of devout families traveled,
they passed more and more ominous landmarks:
human remains, picked clean by scavengers,
dead and discarded pack animals, goods and
garbage that oxen were no longer strong enough
to carry.
Native tribes tested, every night — the
caravan would wake to find some of their animals
gone, and fear was nearly tangible.
Fear among those who had faith not quite as
strong as Brewster's, that is: even as workers
on the US mail train warned them that it wasn't
safe, he insisted their faith would protect
them from whatever dangers they might face.
So, you might be able to see why the Oatman
family only traveled with the rest of the
Brewerites as far as Las Vegas.
That, historians say, is when the party split:
26 people, including the Oatmans and three
other families, set off in the direction of
California, while the others followed their
prophet.
The splinter group headed along the El Camino
Real, and in January of 1851, they made camp
at La Joya.
They worked for a bit cutting and delivering
hay, before moving on toward Maricopa Wells.
By this time, they knew they were being followed.
Cooler heads prevailed, at first, and the
group decided to wait at the Pima villages
until they were joined by travellers who were
inevitably coming along behind them.
Greater numbers would have made them a less
tempting target, but again, it's possible
to see why they would just want to get on
with their journey and reach their destination.
After three weeks of waiting, Roys decided
that he and his family — including his wife,
who was due to give birth any day — were
going to push on.
They were going to be doing it alone, too,
as no other families would join them.
Their destination was Fort Yuma, 190 miles
away.
That doesn't sound far, in our 21st century
world of wide roads and fast cars, but the
Oatman family would have been trundling along
at a pace that was, at the fastest, between
15 and 20 miles per day.
A lot can happen in that kind of time, and
things did happen.
Horrible things.
The Oatmans decided to take a shortcut, but
they were slowed down even more.
Their oxen were ill-suited to the terrain
they found themselves crossing, and they were
struggling to get up and down the rocky hills
and plateaus.
On February 18, 1851, they spotted a large
group approaching.
There were between 17 and 20 — members of
a Native American tribe that have variously
been called Apache, Yavapai, and Maricopa.
The details of exactly how the confrontation
happened are understandably scarce, but it's
believed Roys approached the group, who demanded
tobacco and pipes.
That, Roys shared, but when they demanded
food, and were not satisfied with the bread
he offered, he told them that he didn't have
enough to feed his own family, much less them.
The conflict escalated, and by the time it
was over, all but three were dead.
In her later memoirs, Olive Oatman described
seeing the broken and bloody bodies of her
family members, scattered across the ground.
Then, she fell into unconsciousness.
Olive and her younger sister, Mary Ann, weren't
killed — they were taken captive, and when
they woke, they spent several days on a march
to the village of their captors.
Almost immediately, they were stripped of
their shoes — making it almost impossible
to walk on their bloody and bruised feet,
much less try to run away.
Olive wrote of those first few days, when
the grief was fresh and they were still coming
to terms with the fact that everything had
changed in a heartbeat.
She wrote of stopping to make camp, of watching
a cooking fire built, saying:
"They boiled some of the beans just from our
wagon, mixed some flour with water, and baked
it in the ashes.
They offered us some food, but in the most
insulting and taunting manner, continually
making merry over every indication of grief
in us, and with which our hearts were ready
to break.
We could not eat."
There was one more survivor: Lorenzo, who
has an important part to play in his sisters'
story.
He survived only by sheer luck, later describing
waking "with the mangled remains of my own
parents lying near by, my scalp torn open,
my person covered with blood, alone, friendless,
in a wild, mountain, dismal, wilderness region,
exposed to the ravenous beasts, and more,
to the ferocity of more than brutal savages
and human-shaped demons."
Incredibly, he managed to make his way back
to the Pima village and the safety they had
left behind, joining up with another group
heading to California.
Along the way, he and the family who had taken
him in stopped at the site of the massacre.
The Oatmans were buried in a mass grave, and
Lorenzo would embark on a quest to find his
sisters — who were not among the dead.
From slave to treasure
Mary Ann barely survived the march to the
village, carried part of the way by one of
their captors when she grew so weak — and,
Olive later said, so "utterly fearless of
death" — that she could no longer walk.
Nevertheless, they made it to camp: the arrival
of the raiding party was greeted with dancing,
singing, and merry-making, and Olive's description
of life among them isn't for the faint of
heart.
They described a village where women were
"the laborers and principal burden-bearers,"
and where she and her sister were immediately
put to work as slaves; only the slightest
excuse was needed for whippings and beatings
to be handed out, but it was the foreboding
sense that something much worse was waiting
just around the next corner, just coming with
the new dawn, that truly took a toll.
Olive later wrote,
"There was no beauty, no loveliness, no attractions
in the country possessed by these unlovely
creatures [...] Sometimes I would tell [Mary]
that I saw but little chance for escape; that
we had better be good and ready for any fate,
and try to wait in submission for our lot."
Months into their captivity, and Olive wrote
that they became more "merciful," in large
part because of her sister, and in part because
of their skill at learning their captors'
language.
The women and children they met were particularly
fascinated with their stories of their home,
of the ocean, and of their travels.
Among themselves, though, Olive described
a spirit of "low obscenity and meanness,"
and they would regularly ask the girls if
they wanted to escape — a question they
didn't dare answer honestly.
Fortunately for the girls, a nearby group
of Mohave had been trading with this group
for several years.
And finally, they came — only after, Olive
said,
"Months rolled by, finding us early and late
at our burden-bearing and torturing labors,
plying hands and feet to heed the demands
of our lazy lords, and the taunts and exactions
of a swarm of heathen urchins, sometimes set
over us."
The Mohave emissary was made up of five men
and one woman; her appearance gave the girls
hope that if they were sold, they may find
their lot in life even slightly improved.
And they were sold — the Mohave paid for
them in horses, blankets, and food.
They were on the move again, and ten days
later, they came to the Mohave village.
Here, Olive wrote, they found a home.
They were welcomed into the chief's home,
and taken into the care of his wife.
The woman who had negotiated for their purchase
had been the chief's daughter, and her sympathy
toward their plight gave them the better life
they hadn't dared to dream of, much less speak
of.
While the sisters had been shocked at their
captors' lifestyle and their apparent inability
to survive on anything that they hadn't killed
or stolen, their Mohave family even gave them
their own plot of land to grow crops.
They were expected to contribute to the tribe's
welfare, and they did: they gathered wood,
dug for roots, planted and harvested crops,
and foraged for berries.
They made friends, too.
They were given nicknames, and the facial
tattoo that would make Olive's appearance
so distinctive — and strange, in the eyes
of the world she had been born into.
It was done to both Mary and Olive, and it
was a painful process.
Their skin was pricked and a pigment made
from the powder of river rocks and the juice
from weeds was rubbed into their bloody skin.
Painful, yes, but it was a mark of friendship
and of respect.
They were family.
And as family, the Mohave did all they could
when Mary Ann grew weaker and weaker.
She died in 1855, after a long illness caused
by a lack of nutrition.
It wasn't just Mary Ann, either — drought
had made food scarce, and Olive later remembered
traveling for days to find berries that would
sustain the dying for just a little longer.
She helped tend to the sick, administered
medicine, and felt the devastation that came
with failure.
Then, she would travel for days again, searching
for bird eggs, for roots, for anything that
could prolong her sister's life until the
rivers were filled with fish again.
But for all her efforts, and the efforts of
the chief and his family, Mary Ann passed
away.
"She sank into the sleep of death as quietly
as sinks the innocent infant to sleep in its
mother's arms," Olive would later remember.
While tradition dictated that the bodies of
the tribe's dead were to be cremated, the
chief's wife appealed to her husband to allow
Olive to do as she wished with her sister's
body, and she was ultimately buried according
to her own traditions.
Now, Olive was truly alone, save the continued
kindness of the chief's wife and daughter,
which she said sustained her more than any
bit of gruel or handful of corn.
The desperate search of a heartbroken brother
Years passed, and Lorenzo never gave up the
search for his sisters.
He joined expeditions of explorers and prospectors,
he searched the length and breadth of southern
California for even the slightest bit of information
or indeed, of hope they were still alive.
He even petitioned the governor of California
for help, and got a response he hadn't wanted:
the governor had no authority to do anything.
Lorenzo's determination kept the girls' plight
the talk of the towns.
And that meant he wasn't the only one looking
for his sisters; in 1853, a man named Henry
Grinnell passed through Fort Yuma and heard
the tale of the two young girls who had been
taken captive.
Finding those who were lost was in his blood:
he was the nephew of another Henry Grinnell,
who used the profits from his shipping company
to fund the voyages that went in search of
Sir John Franklin, who went missing during
his attempts to find the Northwest Passage.
Our Grinnell was a carpenter, but an inquisitive
one.
He asked so many questions for so long, that
he was finally approached by a Native American
man who had some information.
His name was Francisco, and he asked Grinnell
about the girls in January of 1856.
Grinnell — who pretended to get his information
directly from the newspaper he was holding
— told Francisco that the American government
knew there were two girls being held against
their will somewhere in the southwest.
He added that they were prepared to go to
war to save them…
unless, that is, their captors saw fit to
release them.
Francisco promised to bring the girls to safety,
in exchange for a few blankets and some beads.
He only asked for 20 days, and promised he
would return.
Even as Grinnell was ridiculed for his faith
that the emissary would, indeed, do all he
could to rescue the girls, Francisco really
did head off to the Mohave tribe where Olive
still lived.
For her part, Olive knew that the attitudes
of the chief and his wife seemed to change,
and finally, she came to realize that someone
was, indeed, trying to bargain for her release.
The Mohave didn't want to let her go, though,
even going as far as to tell Francisco that
this wasn't the girl he was looking for.
She wasn't American, they insisted, she was
from a far away tribe that lived in the same
direction as the setting sun.
They told Olive to tell Francisco the same,
but when it came time for her to talk, she
told the truth.
She was threatened with torture, called a
liar, told they were simply not going to let
her go.
But they did: a beautiful white horse was
added to seal the deal, and Olive visited
her sister's grave one last time before she
left for Fort Yuma.
Reacclimation wasn't easy for Olive; she had
transitioned almost completely from speaking
English, and when she — accompanied by the
chief's daughter — returned to the fort,
she was quickly given more "appropriate" clothing
to wear.
She was given over to the care of women working
in the fort, and Lorenzo read about her return
in the same paper Grinnell had pretended to
read from.
Confirming it was true, he headed back to
Fort Yuma and they were quickly reunited.
Here is about where Lorenzo's part in the
story ends.
He traveled with his sister for a bit, living
with her in California and New York.
He eventually married and got into the hotel
business, and died unexpectedly in 1901.
As for Olive, she struggled to readjust to
the life she'd been taken from.
She kept her promise to the Mohave: whenever
she spoke about them, she told stories of
how kind they had been.
She denied that she had ever suffered at their
hands, and after the Reverend Royal Byron
Stratton wrote a slightly embellished account
about her life among the Mohave, she used
a part of the profits from the book and her
time on the lecture circuit to send both her
and her brother to college.
In 1865, she married John Fairchild.
They moved to Texas, and after 10 years, they
adopted a baby girl.
She died in 1903, and although she occasionally
used makeup to cover her tattoos for pictures,
she never entirely turned her back on the
way of life taught to her by the Mohave.
Until she died, she always kept a jar of hazelnuts
in her kitchen — one of the staple foods
she had once collected for her second family.